how's it going bros my welcome to as you
bros know i swear a lot in my videos and
and and I want you brooch to know that
swearing is good swearing is not bad
swear all you want but sometimes you
just can't do it you might get in
trouble for it so I'm gonna teach you
how to swear in Swedish so if sometimes
you need to swear just go full suite on
it and and no one will know what you're
saying unless you're in Sweden you might
know some of these already by watching
my videos and I think I explain some of
these before but we're gonna go really
in depth so the first word is a thumbs
it's basically means damn so it's not
it's not really that bad abhorred swear
word it's more of a like a supplement
swear word you could also say a thumbs
bun all Natick which means damn bananas
which for some reason is a swear word
the thing about Swedish swear words is
that don't ask questions alright or
another alternative to say damn would be
like gums like gums which is like shoot
I would say shoot moving on if you want
to not just say damn and you want to say
damn it for some reason
these are really funny words to me I
don't know if they're funny to you for
the boss kept for Buskett it means damn
it or you could say I really like a
pissed-off damn it I would say would be
far above or Len I don't think I heard
anyone say that word in like 10 years
but it's a really funny swear word if if
life is not fair to you you can just
randomly shoutout for Marlon the more
you know a direct translation of it
would be
the executioner which is kind of weird
don't ask questions remember now we're
gonna move on to a little bit more rough
swear words first one of these is a road
it's spelled with the O with two dots
over it and Americans are foreigners
always struggle to save this letter we
pronounce it like o or like if someone
is far away and you want to call them
you can just go like oh oh dude come in
facade but basically that's how it's
pronounced so if you want to say ass in
Swedish you say you're old
it's basically mean asks if you want to
say ass [ __ ] you say a rubber ball
next one isn't so bad either actually
it's just your mom in case you wanted
your mom someone but you you're too
hipster to do it in English you can do
it in Swedish and then you say Dean mama
D mama your mom simple the next word is
probably the most Swedish swear word you
could possibly say
yeah blah which basically means [ __ ] but
it can be used in a lot of different
ways it's a very elaborate [ __ ] you want
to say you [ __ ] idiot you say Dean
yeah blah idiot
good word yeah play is a good word I
think it's based on the devil like yeah
yeah Bootle means devil so I think
that's where it comes from next one is a
word that you probably heard in my
videos many times for some reason saying
[ __ ] in Swedish is a very common swear
word and we say PITA
it's very rude word I would say I mean
it means [ __ ] but we use it kind of as
[ __ ] or as dammit or if you want to say
you you're you [ __ ] [ __ ] you can say
Dean job la Fitte
that's a good that's a good swear word
that'll now get your message across and
I'm teaching kids all these great words
I feel proud of myself
next word is hell back there he'll bet
that it kind of means [ __ ] hell
putting in one word so we can be used in
different things if something is really
annoying you you can just shout out
helmet that are your baton which
basically means so [ __ ] annoying
and the final Swedish word is fun not
not you bros not fans but fun
it's probably the closes to [ __ ] it's
weird how we have so many different
words that can be used as [ __ ] and all
these kind of different things I mean
they're all very different swear words
but they all kind of mean the same thing
it's just the context matters my
favorite way to use fun would probably
be if I'm really annoyed and I'll just
say man I'm Auto fun which basically is
well [ __ ] hell kind of like I'm so
annoyed man Navarro fun if Edgar shits
on the floor I'll be like many more fun
at Gap be sleek alien oh so there you
have it please take this knowledge and
use it wisely so now you can swear
around your parents and they don't know
what they're you're saying but yeah
that's it for this week's prize if you
enjoyed something or learned something
please go ahead and leave a like for
every every like this video gets paid
the life of the swear thank you both so
much for watching I will see you in the
next video as always they never stops
does it I just keep making them crazy
after the video please break the promise